I just found out on the homeless person
stole a recycling bin not sure if I'm
supposed to be angry her the flag man
what's going on YouTube oh I got the
pastor hair going on again yeah Jeanne
just say but the whole of your life now
if you haven't read this article well
this was a doozy now apparently in San
Francisco there was a situation where a
man was walking with his girlfriend and
while he was walking with her there was
another man that was catcalling now
obviously he's with this girl so we
asked him to stop but because he did the
do stabbed in nine times and according
to a friend that was there all he said
to the guy was can you please stop now
if you've been keeping up with social
media there's been a lot of attention
that's been drawn towards catcalling so
if any of you out there don't quit
catcalling his catcalling is basically a
dude trying to holla at a girl in the
most skiis ball type of way [__] where
you going with that 'are you smuggling
mijin them today let's get butt-naked
greasy now for me as a male I'm not a
fan of catcalling and in fact I dislike
it but it was something that I saw a lot
growing up and I'll be straight up with
you I started work a couple of times but
in all obviously that [__] was creepy as
hell oh you don't learn and at what time
I tried catcalling at a girl when I was
younger because I thought it was cool I
crumbled like a little [__] see the
problem with me is that when I said some
stupid [__] and they came back at me
with a straight answer that [__] would
throw me off stop mama where you're
going back home to my husband and
children why okay well I bet you go tuck
them in read them a bedtime I can't do
this I you know it's [__] to the times
it won't work but there will be an
occasional hood rat that will respond
with whatever
okay I'll feed you I'll feed you huh and
the moment of guy gets that one
affirmation with that one technique
that's the technique he's gonna be using
you know what the WIC [__] about these
cases is that this guy was so adamant in
his right to Catco whoever the [__] he
wants that he was willing to kill for
money that [__] makes absolutely no
sense now if you come up and you say
something very disrespectful to another
man's girlfriend you best believe he has
every right to tell you to stop and
anything if he didn't have forgot to
stop he would be in more trouble and
most likely his girlfriend with a stab
the [__] out of him why don't you say
anything
well because you know you uh-oh I'm
[__] stab you now if you ask me if I
do with direct
disrespect my girlfriend from me you
best believe I might do something I
listen I'm not stupid I have to assess
the situation now that I see how tall he
is one neighborhood we in if he crazy
and if he got crazy I'm your man tell
you right now if he got crazy on us and
[__] up eyebrows
[__] is giving you a compliment take
it look I know what you're thinking vans
I huckle do be such a pig let me ask you
something why do you stop damn selfish I
gotta get stabbed up every time I defend
you and [__] ah fish it's real why would
you even think I was gonna defend you
ain't got no muscle fibers on my body
you dated a guy they look like a
real-life Tamagotchi now you guys want
to know if he's okay
yes I heard the dude is fighting he's on
his way to a full recovery but the fella
is not cut i'ma tell you right now sir
best believe if I ever see you were
public [__] I got a rape flute and some
pepper spray [__] it will be the
occasional hood rat rat what the [__]
a hood rat cousin Vietnamese hood rat
hello land a watch that you have friend
now if you guys want to know if the guys
okay yes he is perfectly fine iron her
laughing JA feed you